my name is Ed Sakura I'm an extension
plant pathologist with the Auburn
University my email in case you want to
contact me later is
s-i-k-o-r-e-j at auburn.edu
I also post a lot on Twitter and my
Twitter handles Alabama Ed but
post a lot of pictures of sick plants
start off with some healthy looking
strawberries this is down at uh
slide on the left is Burrs Farms down in
Baldwin County or in Foley Alabama many
of you probably know
his operation he's been doing it for 30
years does a great job
um walked through that field and
could not find any disease that day
which
I guess I was happy to see on the right
is a nice basket of fresh strawberries
picked a Dempsey Farm which is just
North of Auburn near uh south of
Lafayette that's pretty much what you're
you're aiming for to produce as a grower
unfortunately
you get problems like this and
Leaf plates on the left you get a root
rots and Crown rots in the center and
also fruit grass
on the right which are showing up right
about now and all these can be
cost a significant amount of money and
in some cases devastate the crop
I like to start off with just this
simple definition of what a plant
disease is and I Define it as any
disturbance of a plant that interferes
with its normal growth and development
talk about biotic diseases which are
caused by living agents such as bacteria
fungi nematodes viruses and then abiotic
diseases caused by non-living agents
often uh related of Mother Nature maybe
flooding
of
uh cold weather and so forth Frost
injury
just a couple of examples of abiotic
diseases uh this poor pollination I saw
up in Edgar's area up in Clanton uh
possibly this poor pollination
leading to this disfigured fruit kind of
looks like a bird a ride with sun scald
some fruit on a black plastic malishes
years ago but it went from relatively
cold or warm those fruit were exposed
and he had damage that so abiotic
problems are out there insect problems
are out there like Ashley just talked
about we're going to talk about
strawberry diseases
um broke these down into a a few Leaf
spots both fungal and bacterial uh two
Crown rots root rots and anthracnose and
phytopra then we'll talk more more
heavily on the fruit rots which are
probably the most obvious ones
especially this time of year during
harvest season so botrytus and
threctnose fruit rod
new disease that Dr Connor in our
Diagnostic lab detected uh not long ago
this year and also rise of this route
which oftentimes shows up
post Harvest many times in your in your
kitchen in your refrigerator or on your
uh
encounter
as far as the least spots are concerned
we do have a couple fungal leaf spot
problems that are are common in backyard
gardens more than in commercial Fields
I'd say this is strawberry leaf spot or
common leaf spot uh
caused by a fungal pathogen oftentimes
you see these uh tan the brown lesions
surrounded by a darker margin these
could be red to purple and color you can
see on the left many of these lesions
start to emerge and you get blighting of
the foliage and eventually fall off and
typically these show up on the older
leaves
of the plant and it's look if you're not
on a fungicide spray program uh these
These are going to probably pop up
this is a strawberry Leaf blight another
disease sometimes you see both those
diseases on the same plant uh oftentimes
you get these tannish lesions
in the center you can see some
target-like patterns developing
on the right you can see where these
lesions start to merge and many times
you'll see almost like a U or a v-shaped
lesion extending out to the leaf Edge
and that leaf eventually uh turns brown
and dies both of these diseases are are
pretty
easily controlled with uh fungicides
so with common it's a it first appears a
small round purplish red spots on the
upper Leaf surface
uh Leaf death can occur when numerous
spots merge
and many of these this is often
introduced into fields on Infected
transplants and I highlight infected
transplants because I think with just
about every disease I talk about today
one of the ways the disease gets started
is coming in on Infected material
a commonly spot is spread within a field
by splashing water High rainfall warm
temperatures will favor rapid disease
development
as far as Leaf blight the spots become
target-like and only have a purple or
yellow or even a yellow margin to them
older lesions are as I mentioned I
usually v-shape at the leaf Edge leading
to a blight of the entire leaf
and similar weather conditions favor uh
Leaf blight as Leaf spots so that's why
I say oftentimes you might see these
together in the same field
I mentioned resistant varieties I
believe there are a few that have
resistance to these pathogens
disease-free transplants when you do get
your transplants in clean up some of the
dead tissue on them and then applying a
protective fungicide so a product like
Captain applied before these diseases
show up control them well caftan some of
the other
protective materials that are used by
commercial Growers do do a great job on
keeping these in check and more times
than not I see it late in the season
when the budget side programs have been
abandoned or in a home Garden situations
next disease is angular leaf spot and
this is a bacterial disease it's only
bacterial disease we'll talk about today
but it gets its name from the very sharp
angles to the lesions caused by the
pathogen
the bacteria get inside the leaf tissue
but they have a hard time Crossing some
of those major veins so you get these
these sharp angular lesions so it's
fairly easy to pick up in the field once
you get used to seeing it typically it's
a cooler weather disease likes it wet
like most of these diseases but a cooler
weather pathogen
So It Begins as
small water silk yellow lesions on the
lower leaf
yellow flesh will develop on the upper
surface and they'll eventually turn that
reddish brown color
and the elysians will enlarge to become
these angular spots uh short and merge
more or less and they're limited by the
lead veins
symptoms could also be visible on the
calyx of the fruit and I'll show you a
Sly of this but the bacterium does not
actually go to the fruit but that calyx
damage that does reduce marketability of
that infected fruit
now the bacterium can't survive on dead
leaves in the field so it can be there
from one year to the next it could also
be introduced on transplants
and then plant the plant movement uh
within the field is by splashing water
and I mentioned cooler temperatures
favor angular Leaf Spa
so with management we're looking at
disease-free planting stock purchasing
from a reputable dealer I do recommend
copper fungicides when this disease
shows up as they can be effective in
reducing bacterial problems and also
help you with some of your fungal
response you got to watch with coppers
and sulfur products some of these
products because they can cause a foliar
burn if they're overused or if
temperatures suddenly you know in
Alabama they might be 90 degrees
tomorrow some of these products can't be
more can cause actual Burns in a plant
and cause more damage than the pathogen
itself so be careful with them read the
label before using any product
so a couple early uh development of
angularly spot on the left and Center if
you were to cut one of those lesions
with a razor blade stick it on a die set
or a micro a compound scope in the lab
which you would see would be bacterial
ooze coming out and that's that gray and
a slide on the right the uh
that gray mass of spores coming out
there's probably thousands of bacterials
whereas oozing from one single lesion
and that's why these diseases really
take off these bacterial problems under
the right conditions
so with angular leaf spot uh we
mentioned water silky and an example of
that is on the left on the lower half of
that leaf you can see kind of a
just a dark almost like a water droplet
that's drying off that's water soaking
and that'd be the initial symptom for
angular leaf spot you could hold those
leaves up to the Sun as I did on the
right and then you can see those yellow
flecks where the pathogen causes initial
affection site and then eventually
that'll turn reddish from the bacterium
moving and reproduce rapidly
rip
and there's damage on the calyx I
mentioned and this I I noticed uh years
ago now but uh
I was able to get bacteria loose from
the calyx uh that dries down making that
that fruit a little bit less
likely to be picked by a you picker in
your operation
um it doesn't go to the fruit
but damage has already been done when
that fruit looks unedible
so angular leaf spot not a problem this
year at least I haven't seen it in a
couple years to be honest with you but
uh it's out there along with your other
Leaf puts
wanted to move down into the soil into
the crown of the plant a couple crown
and root rot diseases namely uh interact
nose Crown rot and then phytopter a root
and Crown rot and uh phytopus
we had that probably the most common
problem coming through the Diagnostic
lab according to Dr Connor our our fine
diagnostician uh attract nose Crown Rod
oftentimes if it comes in on transplants
it could be a significant problem to
Growers
on the left what happens is they they'll
plant their plants and then in in a
short time many of these plants will
start to die off you see a plant in the
center that has uh both phytopter and
spider mites uh Ash had a nice slide it
almost looks identical to that one
on the right is uh what I believe is
vital for Dr Connor noticed this field
in uh Brewton a few a couple months ago
diagnosed by top or in the field and the
grower lost plants but with vitopter
sometimes those plants will revive
themselves basically but they'll be show
that stunting that you see on the right
side of that bed
so with anthracnose what you're going to
see is uh
well it may attack the crowns direct no
says there's three different species of
them correct those and some are more
common as one is more common for the
crown Rod phase
and I'll talk about interact notes fruit
Rod later which is typically a different
species
so you get different phases of the same
disease
but plants may die after being
transferred to the field infected plants
the wilted plants will have a reddish
brown uh Crown so if you you cut the
crown open longitudely and I'll show you
a slide of this you'll see a this
discoloration on the inside it'll be a
firm Rod of the crown
um can be hard to ID based on Crown
symptoms of dying plants because the
crowns typically turn brown in short
order so
um which the same thing happens with
frost injury uh flooding of a plant dies
the crown is going to turn brown in in a
short period of time
but infected transplants seem to be the
main source of the disease in Alabama
so with management you want to plant the
Z Street material when possible hard to
pick up this disease by looking at the
transplants as they come in
Scout the field early on and remove
dying plants as soon as possible so even
in the fall after after planting or in
early winter period look for plants that
are dying check to see if they might
have symptoms of anthracnose and then
discard those as quickly as possible so
it doesn't spread then as the season
progresses you want to follow protect
the fungicide program early in the
season to try and keep that disease in
check
on the left you can see it on the upper
Leafs upper left corner that plant
starting to die down
if you what you want to do is uh
sacrifice one of those plants that is
still green but obviously on its way out
and cut the stem open the crown open and
that's when you're going to see this
reddish brown discoloration
you wait for the plant to be completely
Brown it's just going to be about
and you see uh just
symptoms of anthracnose on the left from
a healthy Crown to one that is uh
completely
been destroyed by it basically as a firm
or out remember picture on the right is
what I just showed you earlier so
dracnose Crown wrap uh significant
disease when it does show up
now if I top through a root in Crown rot
uh we used to call these water mold
fungi
um
guess that name from the the wet
conditions that this pathogen prefers
and you'll often see plants like the one
on the left that just suddenly Wilt and
die you don't see a progression of the
disease it just it goes down quickly
slice the stem open on that again you'll
look for maybe a pinkish rose color but
it can also be reddish brown to Brown
in the crown
usually on the upper part of the crown
some pictures from Dr Connor to share
with me from the lab from earlier this
year I believe but you can see uh phytop
there
or crown rot and some of the symptoms
inside of those crowns
so this disease really likes it wet
that's that's the main thing with these
water mold pathogens so symptoms begin
in the upper part of the crown uh young
Lisa will suddenly and you'll get
complete collapse excuse me of the plant
uh within days
and the plan sometimes will break at the
upper part of the crown when you try and
lift it from the soil uh quickly
cut that Crown longitudally you may see
a rose pink discoloration usually in the
upper part of the crown or it can be
brown and eventually that'll just
disintegrate
now when the disease is not bad and when
conditions dry out maybe you get some
warm temperatures some of these plants
will recover
but they're usually going to be stunted
and not produce as much as a healthy
plant during the season
warm wet conditions poorly drained soils
favor infection
so management especially in a commercial
field because phytopter can't survive in
the soil is as clusters of resistant
type spores fumigation would be an
option if you have a limited space for
planting or if you have a heavy
infection there are resistant varieties
available and you want to provide good
soil drainage when choosing a site and
you want to avoid low wet fields or
fields that have a history of this
disease because it can be quite
devastating when it gets going
left you could see a plant that
eventually uh was infected with
phytopper on the right is a slide I
showed you earlier but you see those
plants appeared to recover from
phytother but they're what about one
one-fifth the size of those healthy
plants in the left
oftentimes you might see them in a row
or a few plants together where the
disease is spread from one plant to the
next office
okay let's get to the cool diseases the
fruit rots and these this is what you're
seeing now if you if you're uh
taking your crop or if you have if
you're you picking yourself gray mold
detritus gray mold on the left
and on the right you could see
anthracnose fruit rod
and gray mole of course gets his name
from the
so here's just different different uh
levels of infection on strawberry fruit
from left to right but that gray stuff
you see there is fungal mycelium the
body of the fungus along with spores on
the right it almost looks of that fruit
is mummified by the path
this this stands out pretty much in the
field I'm sure any of you who've walked
through strawberries or grow
strawberries have seen this problem it's
an annual problem in Alabama
a little more common when we have uh wet
conditions like we had last year
especially in in some cases in some
parts this year this is just a
close-up of what the that mycelium looks
like these individual Haifa and the blue
and then off the hyphy you get these
clusters of botrytus spores on the left
hand side of the screen looks like a
somebody's bringing over some flowers
and then under in that star you can see
a couple individual spores and if you
see botritus in the field
and if you just see that gray Mass on
this on the fruit just flick it with
your finger sometime if it's dry and
you'll just see these four clouds come
off and that's individual spores being
released one of those spores laying on a
neighboring fruit and that can infect
the fruit directly so uh gives you some
idea how rapid
this packaging or how aggressive it can
be
this was in an organic field last year
in our region but you can see that
growing mold for me again if you just
flick that with your finger you would
see a massive spores blown off
typically these fruit might show some
darkening first but the mold comes off
fairly quickly
I mentioned it comes in on transplants
now this is a garden store in uh Lee
County that I when I when I go to a
garden store I look for diseases I mean
most of you are probably picking out
nice strawberry fruit or healthy flowers
I look for problems this was just from a
basket of strawberries being sold these
were probably the last six plants left
on the star shelf but they had a fruit
on them which was interesting but it
also had gray mold on them so this is
something you wouldn't want to bring
into your home Garden say and definitely
obviously with a commercial grower you'd
want to avoid this but
it was just sort of interesting on a at
least in the garden center
made for a nice picture
so would betrayed as gray mold it's it's
widespread has numerous hosts
survives and dead plant material
free water cool temperatures favorite
development so right now it's ideal uh
with the rain we had in recent days
green berries appear to be more
resistant to infection than red berries
uh management is to avoid disease
transplants which is hard to do and
avoid allowing over ripened fruit to sit
in the field that's probably the biggest
problem where Growers have extended
themselves uh more Acres than they
needed they can't pick them fast enough
in these fruits just start to rot in the
field so what you'd like to do is remove
and destroy the diseased fruit and uh
Ash earlier talked about removing fruit
with damage from insects and the same
thing with botrytus you would like to
get take those fruit off the plant and
then get them out of the field bury them
um I know a number of Growers that they
have time to remove the fruit throw them
in the center of the road but then they
they leave them there they don't they
can't pick them up because they don't
have enough time throwing enough people
power and that's still a source of
inoculum
this disease can be controlled with with
fungicides on a strict schedule uh you
need to get ahead of it caftan is always
a nice product to to add to your mix but
there's a number of other products of
different chemistries that are available
uh Dr Connor Dr Vincent and myself have
been doing uh
we've been doing some resistant
profiling of fields over the last year
and a half looking for uh
populations of botrytus that are
resisted to different fungicide classes
working with a professor over the
University of Georgia we're continuing
this project but we but we found about
80 percent of the fields that
um many that many of the botrytus
populations were resistant to uh class
one I believe was class 11 fungicide so
products like top semam would be uh
people spraying it were were not having
any benefits from it and uh I think I
think class 11 was the other one we were
having problems with uh things like
abound just not effective any longer and
that's problem throughout the southeast
it's not in Alabama
now with direct nose fruit Rod is also
occurring we saw it in about 25 percent
of the fields last year also seeing
resistance to this fellow in a in some
of the products
but we don't see it as
common as botrytus but it was out there
last year and I did see it this year
has that Telltale kind of a sunken area
on the fruit uh they could range from
tan to Brown to uh black
on the right there was a field down
brooding that had five or six fruit on
one plant uh you have to just just move
from plant to plant
just different examples of anthracnose I
think the one in the upper left-hand
corner you can see the initial symptom
and it almost looks like a thumb print
on these
in that one but that might be the
initial symptom and then you start
getting more darkening of the tissue
and the spores are then produced off
that tissue as well
so the source of the pathogen is also
from Nursery stock but it's hard to
detect coming on in
disease itself is favored by rain high
humidity warm temperatures all common
situations in Alabama
rain and wind can spread the disease
across the field fairly quickly
and then the dark lesions can form on
green fruit but also on mature fruit as
well
then management is to buy plants from a
repeal Nursery one that you or your
colleagues have had luck with in the
past
uh plant anthracnose resisting cultivars
I I threw sweet Charlie up here as one
and I Edgar I hope that's that's the
correct variety but there are some
available for resistance to anthraktos
and you want to monitor fields for hot
spots of interactives and then remove
infected plants not just the fruit but
whole affected plants you might be able
to limit the amount of damage you've
seen a feel from this disease or amount
of spread so the grower I talked to who
had anthracnose on his fruit a couple
weeks ago I told him remove that plant
and a couple plants next to it and he
might be able to compartmentalize that
disease and a keep it from spreading
rapidly
another disease when you take those
fruit off you also want to get them out
of the field Sanitation
so management there is a pre-planned dip
that uh doctor uh Edgar discussed in a
publication a couple years ago so
certain fungicides uh one we use is
switch can be used as dips on your
transplants to reduce incidence of
anaphorectos and gray mole before
planting
and typically when your transplants come
in you you mix up the solution of the
Fungicide and then submerge the
transplants in the dip for at least or
dip them in in the solution for at least
two minutes and then plant and that can
reduce to your initial and oxygen load
uh if you have problems you want to
begin fungicide program early and follow
the guidelines and I would I would
follow the guidelines outline in the
Southeast Regional strawberry IPM guide
2022.
uh I'm not going to go through all the
chemicals because it gets complicated
very quickly but the website's down in
the bottom but if you just get your
go to your Google machine and type in
southeast strawberry IPM guide
2022 and it'll take you to that link and
then uh there's great information I
think Ash mentioned uh on uh insect
control weed control uh variety
selection and also on Disease Control I
think on pages 45 to 50 they outline
disease resistance management promote
them threat no sound bertritis
but it's very complicated to try and
explain it in a short webinar would be
would be
two more diseases I wanted I want to
mention one is Rise of this Fruita this
is one that
have you ever left
a carton of strawberries on your counter
for any length of time or even in the
refrigerator this is what you might have
seen looks like your your strawberries
have grown a beard this is also known as
old old gray man's beard we have a white
to gray tint to it
sometimes rise of this which is a fungal
disease is joined by another pathogen
name known as mucer
um both together or sometimes they can
be confused I confuse them
the blackberries on the right I found
those in my refrigerator a couple weeks
ago after a short vacation so made for a
good picture and for this seminar but uh
so rise was fruit Roth It's a fungal
pathogen
lives on decaying organic matter
the initial affection appears as
discolored water soaked spot on the
fruit
sometimes tannish looking and somewhat
soft fruit appears to be wounded or
where you wounded the fruit that's where
this fungus will attack
um under conditions of high relative
humidity barriers will become covered
with this coat of white mycelium that's
it's fungal growth that that hair you're
seeing
and that uh management is removed plant
debris this organic matter remove ripe
berries as soon as possible for Harvest
don't let them sit out in the field and
then maybe be gentle when you're picking
avoid bruise in the fruit which can
increase incidence of Horizons that
wound that you cause then a rapid
post-harvest schooling I think Ash
mentioned that as far as insect control
as well
uh cooling them down it's not going to
stop the disease but it will slow it
down
we don't recommend fungicides for
rhizopus it's mainly a cultural cultural
practices will reduce this problem
last disease I wanted to talk about is a
new disease for Alabama
neopestal lab neopestalo
lociopsis such a terrible name
Dr Connor found this down in Bruton back
in
it was March Mr degree down air new
grower for the state this is a disease
it's a fungal disease that was detected
in Florida about three years ago uh more
recently detected in Georgia also in
Michigan Texas and a few other places
but Dr Connor was able to First find it
in Alabama down in South Alabama and
this is the disease that appears to be
coming in on transplants but once it
gets into the field it can survive in
the soil and on debris and be a an
annual problem and it can be a severe
problem
and you can see some of the significant
least spots on that plan on the left
and then I took the pictures in the
center and the right but you can see the
least spot there but then going and
going to the fruit and you get a lesion
that looks a little bit like uh
like anthracnose fruit rot but it's it's
much I would say massive compared
comparison to interactive I should have
had them side by side for a year but
then you get that black fruiting
structures growing in that lesion itself
here's more pictures from what I
collected a few weeks ago
so uh really a nasty disease so it can
cause extreme yield loss it can destroy
entire Fields it's happening in Florida
you can't spread quickly to other fields
or within a within a field into other
fields nearby once it is introduced rain
events definitely uh
aggravated or I should say uh help it
out and spread it causes a leaf and
fruit spot as I showed you initially but
eventually it can infect the roots and
the crowns of plants causing plant death
and that's where we're really getting
concerned with
so with management you want to limit
operations when uh when plants are wet
to avoid movement of this disease if you
do see the disease you want to remove
those infected plants as soon as
possible and where practical
because you can't stop it from spreading
and of course you want to get those
plants out of the field so it doesn't
establish in the soil itself
so there's been work done at Florida
where they've had the disease for a few
years
they've been doing fungicide trials and
I think with one year data they saw that
usually something like thyram and switch
rotated with thyram or thyram cap tan
rhyme tilt or Inspire May reduce
incidence on the fruit so they're still
working on this to see how effective
these fungicide programs are uh
Florida's also was evaluating our our
current varieties that are available for
see if any had resistance to disease and
a couple had some I don't say called
tolerance but it appeared to have a
slight level of resistance but nothing
to write home about and there are
programs now trying to develop resistant
varieties to the to this pathogen though
the pathogens is so new that these
programs are just getting started as I
said we've found that just in one field
in Alabama came in on transplants
probably coming from Illinois We Believe
or the Midwest and um
and it was just on one variety coming
from that Nursery out of five that the
grower planted which was interest so we
uh we recommend in his case to destroy
those plants as soon as possible
so with that I will stop uh that is me
after a long day of picking diseases
with a Virgin uh
strawberry daiquiri I believe
but again my name is Ed Sakura with the
Auburn University Cooperative Extension
system you can email me directly at
s-i-k-o-r-e-j at auburn.edu I'll be
happy to talk to you there and then
follow me on Twitter uh if you're
interested in diseases or agriculture in
general I also work with tree fruits
small fruit
vegetables corn and soybeans so and hops
in heaven okay so if you have any
interest in those crops and you're on
Twitter please follow me and then uh
again for Disease Control you really
want to look at the southeast
guide
uh again the 2022 strawberry IPM guide
uh and look at the Z section look at the
fungicides and look at resistance
management that's all very important so
with that I'll stop